this video is brought to you by
maskscape.com
wow the holidays are coming up and i
know it can be tough to shop for us
dudes
but this year you don't have to worry
because the number one thing on a guy's
list
is manscape baby we're talking about the
manscape performance
package right here the all-in-one men's
grooming kit
for the modern day man tame wild nose
and ear hair
with the weed whacker i actually gotta
use that go ahead
the other one thanks
this trimmer is designed for those tiny
holes especially if you're really really
tight you know what i'm talking about
yeah i gotta tighten those
holes and if you need below the waist
trimming we got the lawnmower 3.0 baby
with skin safe technology it's safe to
trim
those sensitive areas because i've
really cut my balls with
other trimmers me too but not this one
and it's got this light too isn't that
cool it's my favorite oh
it's also like used when you cut oh no i
can't find my pubes
you'll get all of this in front of us
plus two free gifts
the shed travel bag and the manscape
anti-chafing boxer briefs smooth
so get the performance package for the
modern day man in your life
their balls well thank you and your
cheeks too
oh yeah her butt cheeks or his butt
cheeks and go to www www.manscape.com
jknews for 20 off plus free
international shipping the link will be
in the description box below so go click
it out
thank you manskip and enjoy this video
do any of you guys decorate your homes
for halloween
halloween or christmas halloween we did
you did it oh yeah it's so cute it's
cute right nikki nikki was doing like a
brand deal thing
yeah for quibby which is hilarious yeah
very funny wait that sounds familiar
what's quibby it's uh
you don't need to learn about it because
it's gone it's gone it's already gone
they just paid us and said sorry and
like sorry our business should tell
that's good
business shut down it's a it's like a
quick app
thingy like quick entertainment like
conductors it's quick little clips when
you're on the go and then covet happen
and they're completely [ __ ]
they tanked after six months of going
live that sucks
but it's [ __ ] hilarious and they had
a lot of starter money
bomb like 30 million or something yeah
whoa
so yeah for that you decorated we did
but like castle was saying
did you even know reno 9-1-1 was on
quibby because well i love that show i
didn't even know that you just told me
that like 20 minutes ago
yeah and i don't even know if it's true
you know that's how bad the marketing
was
in ad for it you know and that was it
so yeah we did it for this brand deal
and it's super fun
i'm glad we did it i think there's two
ways you can go with halloween
decorations you can either go like
put a couple pumpkins in maybe like a a
scaredy cat
you know with the high back or you go
full-blown murder scene
yeah it's a little too real yeah i like
the full-blown
you're a hollywood person that's what
you do halloween's my favorite holiday
however i don't
do the decorations because i think i
have a weird reputation in my
neighborhood already
and and i want it yeah what is it i
think creepy creepy guy with mustache
really yeah that's why i tried to grow a
beard so creepy single guy with
mustaches
creepy single guy yeah they just see me
pop my head out once a day to get the
mail you know and i'm usually in a robe
so it's
i see it um but so if i were the guy
shoveling from home alone
yeah oh yeah he had a heart of gold
though right
that's a [ __ ] classical guy that
saves a day in the horror movie
so um i would like to do a bloody just
you know necks hanging from the tree i
want to do all that
well but it's awesome you're going to
love this story
[Laughter]
go ahead all right so this this house
here
by so there's this artist named steven
he went all out wait here's a
artist's name steve likes no that's
gonna
[ __ ] it that is dope that's exactly what
i'm talking about
i know that's what i said this is
yeah it's a chainsaw it's pretty good oh
this is great
bro this person's like impaled in the
head on the roof
he said he spilled 20 gallons of fake
blood that's gonna stain his [ __ ]
that's what i was thinking too because
that stains your own [ __ ] finger
blood rinses off pressure washer any
good homeowner has one
exactly that's fate as a producer of the
world
famous just kidding films yep yep let me
tell you that should stay
but that's fake blood from the 99 cent
store which is just real blend
so this is what you were thinking
kessinger you're like third act horror
movie
all my lawn exactly i love it i like
that like a whole on scene
i i don't know if you guys my favorite
uh amusement park to go to is the
halloween versions of the amusement like
you know halloween like fortnite like
well i haven't been to the disneyland
one i've been to not scary farm
and it's in the name it's not as scary
as it's really [ __ ] scary
well the universal parking is scary the
parking is terrible it's just filled
with
um people drinking and taking drugs
that's true a lot of raiders fans too
i was gonna say i didn't want to not a
lot of haters
um and so i love the production value of
those haunted mazes and like the
you know and the people scared i get off
on like i
there's a release i regret touching i
know the way you're looking at it
oh no because i'm scared something is
wrong with that guy he is the weird guy
in his neighborhood
i'm picturing what you're saying because
you're describing it so well it's like
it's this vivid thing you know and i
feel it because i'm like completely
terrified so that's where we went
to halloween horror night i liked it i
thought it was cool scary and i don't
get scared of [ __ ] even though i know
it's not real
yeah the insidious house was crashing
was [ __ ] scary
or people run through with the chainsaws
i love that [ __ ]
and they chase you and you just like
stay the [ __ ] away your [ __ ]
they have those knee thingies
i try to pretend like i'm not scared so
they leave me alone so i'm like you do
because they feed they feed on the
energy yeah and then i'm like oh
[ __ ] but sometimes it's fun to scream
and run
it is fun it's like ah you just run and
you let them chase you you're not in my
group how i hate that person
yeah i can't stand that [ __ ] but isn't
it funny because like i'm grown in the
way i look and like i'm getting chased
wait how do you think you look
yeah what is the way you look yeah how
do you think you look i'm not a child
okay okay you're an adult got it yeah
just curious yeah oh let me show you
more photos
so that's the one you saw right that
[ __ ] is too much
is another body it's all pictures crazy
like skulls and a wow do they decorate
like every holiday
it's digital cameras from the 90s do
they go all out on
christmas valentine's day like
everything i would like this house to be
full on every [ __ ] holiday like he
works in hollywood or something what do
you think his valentine
scene would be same orgy
an orgy see yeah that's why something's
wrong with me i'd say it looked the same
it's the same thing but now it's [ __ ]
cupid it's only females
you have to hear the story though
because it's really romantic and
heartbreaking
okay that's right yeah and they're like
some guys i some serial killers do that
i've never i've never done okay
all right well i'm hardcore and i
wouldn't eat it either because it's just
all fat
so you know or i wouldn't barbecue it i
wouldn't like
you know put soy it looks kind of tasty
though or
if they have implants you can sell them
it's just all butter absolutely or you
recycle them
yeah get a nickel okay
anyway so this house is in dallas texas
and uh like i said he used a [ __ ] ton of
fake blood
but he actually has had police cars go
over to his house
and they're saying the cops themselves
actually were like dude [ __ ] props
this shit's amazing it's crazy but we
have to be here
just to fulfill the the complaints from
we wish
we could do that
it's awesome dude i know that's nice
can i take a picture with her can i take
a picture of the house
i'll fire two shots into your lawn oh
yeah no cops are cool
we need them this is uh this is the
steven steve's favorite part of the body
bags
i mean the wheelbarrow barrel flipped
over flipped over with a
bag body bag i had a dream like that it
was so weird
i was chopping up bodies and trying to
clean them up what does it mean i have a
lot of those dreams
you can clean it up maybe you got
secrets i don't know i'm just making it
up
but skeletons in your closet yeah it was
yeah i remember me and my buddy were
just
cutting it up and we're just like in a
rush to do it before someone came over
wow and it was just a weird scene like
we were using kitchen knife i had a
party tonight and i was like [ __ ] man
yeah and we're trying to like
chop it up into pieces and like grind
down the drain it was [ __ ] vivid yeah
i think that's a bomb
okay mine wasn't that nice this was
about six years ago or something like
that
i don't understand interpretations no i
don't have dreams anymore i think
oh because i'm living one yeah
that was really nice i wonder what the
opposite means because i always have
dreams of me getting killed like chased
and getting shot in the back
i always have like burn marks on my back
that sucks oh [ __ ] it just means you're
scared
yeah i'm a scaredy cat huh yeah if only
we had a dream interpreter in here it's
because you're
gonna make some [ __ ] backstabbed or
something yeah that's too easy that's
two on the nose okay
um you uh you're afraid
you uh you are afraid uh wait what was
your dream again i forgot i just i want
to make something
she's getting shot in the back okay um
or actually one time
this murderer came and and i was hiding
in like these plants
and i was just like closing my eyes like
please don't find me but then i opened
my eyes and the gun was right in my
forehead and he shot me
or the shooter and then i was like just
staying standing there i mean
laying there and i felt myself like
dying and my body was getting cold and
all i could think of was
i hope i was a good mother to isaac and
then i woke up crying
that's somebody's sexual fantasy that
whole yeah no it's her old self
no her new self killing her old self
it's it's even simpler than that
she has a fear of farting in public oh
yeah i could see that
fart is the gunshot yeah and it's just
she dies embarrassment dude i full-on
not even kidding had a dream last night
and it was like my grandpa
visiting me because he died years ago
and he was like
hey i just want to let you know like i
love you and like i'm proud of you or
whatever right that's how you know it's
a dream and then i was like oh i was
like this is a dream right i was like
this is a dream isn't it like never said
that dude
no that's how dead people communicate
with us well right but so that's what i
was hoping for right so i was like i was
like
how do i know that this is real to him
right and he's like
he's like there was this old building in
san diego
he's like it was by the it was it used
to be the pfizer building
now it's a qualcomm building and i woke
up and googled it it's not actually
not not at all qualcomm is based in san
francisco
didn't happen so the dream was [ __ ]
future come on tiff the pfizer building
becomes the qualcomm building fights are
doing
so much better than qualcomm yeah yeah i
don't even know the pharmaceuticals
absolutely
yeah that used to be a jc penny you know
what i mean [ __ ] your dead grandpa yeah
i was like should i take anything from
this and then no the answer is no
that really happened i googled all that
this morning and i was like [ __ ]
yeah i was so excited to google that
though oh it's a hell of a way to wake
up
yeah some people make coffee you know
it's
breakfast i had a horrible youtube
research i'm like what part of san diego
is this
yeah i didn't have a dream but i woke up
and i was
really [ __ ] pissed because i wasn't a
famous singer
uh of course and i woke up sad like why
am i not a famous singer like what
happened i had those but it was the
opposite it was me
meeting a famous like it was me meeting
in sync when i was a child and i i woke
up and i was crying because you did it
it was
just a dream well i didn't have a dream
i just woke up entitled you know you
could
you know you can meet in sick now if you
go on certain cruises yeah
i just met lance bass was he in that one
uh he wasn't i don't know that's true
backstreet boys no
he was in in sync but yeah oh you don't
like him
no i'm kidding is it because he was
closeted no for a long time i'm kidding
yeah you didn't like him because he was
a gay there's no way did you sense his
gayness
oh okay we all did i think we all did oh
yeah we all did yeah yeah
it was nice surprise i just thought all
four of them were because
well there we go was he just a gem i've
heard he's just a gym he was
he's so smart and he's like a space guy
he was like changing to be an astronaut
yeah
with the russians he's like a very
surprisingly you know we all knew he was
gay
and uh but he where he surprised us was
with his smarts
i was surprised to know that pop singers
were actually straight
oh yeah yeah that happened well when
ricky martin came out i remember
everyone going
yeah yeah yeah wait he's
yeah yeah no so many hearts broke like
everywhere oh really i don't think
anyone i thought he was a latin lover
so did i with dudes though sometimes
it's a career
like who well youtubers do it oh yeah
even
even straight youtubers will come they
did it it didn't work out
yeah i think that's the best one of the
best moves you can do when somebody says
how do you get subscribers on youtube
that's a number one isn't it more
popular now
to be gay than than back then i think
i i think it's uh there's more of a
community and it's like the the stigma
around
being closeted is not i'm sure it's
still there for a lot of folks and it's
very hard
i wouldn't know i'm just the straightest
guy i've ever known
and but for a lot of folks out there
it's uh because people are getting
called out pretending to be gay no
it's the opposite yeah they're using it
as a way
to like get attention but in reality
they weren't
and that's [ __ ] up it's like stolen
valor you know like faking that you're
in the military or any of those things
and i was like wow but if you think
about it it's kind of like acting too
yeah great actor if you can do it that's
true that's pretty that's pretty good
you